red carpets my God I haven't done red
carpets in so long they're stressful and
I'm just you know I don't know I just
feel like you know if I can skip one uh
I Do Well turns out Ava Mendes is
skipping out on another red carpet this
time her longtime partner Ryan Gosling's
upcoming Barbie Premiere that's just
insane oh my God the star made the
confession after posting a throwback
clip celebrating the 10th anniversary of
her and her Bose film The Place Beyond
the Pines
very soft spot in my heart just very
yeah that's a special movie to me
between seeing the two together on
screen and Barbie's release around the
corner the internet's hoping for a
possible Ryan and Ava moment in front of
the paparazzi I don't speak for Eva
Mendez but Ava crushes those dreams in
the comment section of her post replying
to a fan saying we don't do these things
together you know what I mean like these
photos I've been posting I'm only
comfortable posting because it's already
out there and of course Ava was a step
ahead of any trolls leaving them with
this final thought for those who may
catch me in a lie we only were on the
red carpet together once when promoting
this film sharing that's important
Ava and Ryan have mainly kept their
personal life under wraps but they let
the occasional complimenter 2 slip over
the years you're sitting with Justin
Timberlake instead of your pretty wife
although Justin's kind of pretty that's
what I hear oh that's news to me oh
really you didn't know this I did not
know that he's pretty too not as pretty
as white but no he didn't compare right
that doesn't even really yeah certainly
no comparison try and debate an amazing
Baker and an amazing Chef he's really is
though he's he's
um he's amazing in the kitchen how is
the chemistry with you and Chris Evans
how does it compare it doesn't compare
to the mine with uh
[Laughter]
um at all it doesn't chart and last year
Ava gave a little insight into the start
of her romance with Ryan on the Today
Show well something really crazy
happened was I met Ryan Gosling and I
fell in love with Ryan Gosling and then
I was like oh right
I want your babies really it was until I
met Ryan and fell in love I'm like oh
right I want to create life with you and
it's it's funny because I feel like
parenting is the most creative thing
I've ever done you know I've uh you know
I'm an actress I've designed clothes
I've done you know different number of
different things but this is the most
creative thing is to create life with
them the couple now shares two daughters
and since becoming a mom Ava stepped
away from the Limelight and she's not
particularly nostalgic about her time as
an actress what if I missed
um as far as acting
hmm what have I missed
I don't I don't think I've used any
questions no that just answered the
question that just is a question you
couldn't you got me one thing no
the craft service table those are fun
right uh yeah you got me but Ava's not
ruling out the possibility she's just
got some new criteria now acting is
something that you know I will always
love it's just like now that I have
children I'm kind of extreme there's
just so many things I won't do
like I won't do most of the movies I've
done in the past and I don't want to do
anything too violent of course I don't
want to do anything
too sexual or sexual at all so I
basically like Disney
I'm all yours Disney
[Music]